ha well so the YouTube bots are a little
cleverer than I would have thought I
didn't think I was gonna have a problem
while streaming live I thought it was
only gonna have an issue when this
became archived but no no so apparently
the Box picked up that I was reading a
copyrighted manuscript and shut it down
Oh clever buggers max many changes are
tight yeah so this will just be us
hanging out basically probably until my
water goes cold are you in the back yes
they shut you down real quick yeah I
know I was like it's annoying that it
happened that fast but like honestly
props to the box because it's not
exactly particularly well-known text and
I didn't think they would detect that I
was reading something copyrighted while
I was reading it live I only thought it
was going to be an issue with the wine I
if I tried to archive it but no no they
caught they caught that dang quick yes
why would you take a bath if you're not
gonna have bubbles my goodness darning I
was looking forward to getting a bedtime
story well here's what I may consider
we'll see
and folks would have to realize it's a
work in progress so if you want to hear
dramatic readings from me I may at a
later point opt to read a chapter from
my own work in progress that I'm gonna
wait until things calm down again before
I start a Kickstarter to get that thing
going because I'm gonna publish that
this year however high water but I'm not
gonna do that now because well mainly
because I don't have a manuscript in
front of me to do this I did a reading
an audio book on my channel they never
noticed hmm it's it's funny what they
catch it's pretty amazing that they
picked that up oh right so here's the
thing I was debating as I restarted this
at the last minute turning it into a Q&A
I'm not going to do that because I'm
gonna put that my back pocket for
Saturday um and yeah there are reasons
why that will go down that way and we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it
so instead this just becomes a chance
for us to chat
so okay a random Whovian I it's it's
kind of cute what you've been doing but
you are at this point spamming the chat
with that topic so I am gonna politely
ask that you ease off I haven't even
formally presented my own iteration of
the doctor so it's a bit of a leap to be
asking that in the first place are you
in quarantine sort of um so I'll be
Vermont and we have a stay at home order
so it's not the harshest lockdown that a
governor could theoretically
issue but it does mean that all
non-essential business so anything not
related to food and medicine is closed
so restaurants are stood still doing
takeout obviously the grocery stores are
open the drugstore is open um but
everything else is closed and we are
supposed to stay in our homes now here's
here's the thing you might be thinking
oh great you'll get so far ahead on your
stuff because I won't because I
can actually do my day job from home
which means I am still putting in a full
95 on um even under quarantine so which
I appreciate it means I get to stay my
job it doesn't impact my income and
that's a good thing but I'm not actually
gaming time by this unless you want to
count commute time so maybe an hour a
day I'm gaining and that's about it
so I am gonna try and follow the chap
but since I'm reading it off of my phone
it's gonna whiz by me quickly so I'm
probably gonna miss most of it a
thousand subs he'll do it with the
camera but Justin well no because at a
hundred thousand I will probably
desperately need to maintain what I'm at
and I if I adjust this at a let's say
more enticing angle my whole channel
could get closed down very very quickly
I like the spirit of your idea but the
reality is that that won't work what
kind of wine I'm drinking wine - very
curious this is a mix that I did this is
a Malbec mixed with cranberry juice like
real cranberry juice not cranberry juice
cocktail like the actual onion sugar
stuff that most people cannot swallow I
can swallow it's okay um
somebody's gonna clip that and use it
out of context but yeah so that's it and
that's like trying to come off as not a
complete alcoholic
that's why was as full as it was cuz it
wasn't 100% wine there was other stuff
in there as well that's my story and I'm
sticking to it
it's like sugared Mexican restaurant
like I'm supposed to be getting I'm on
school work and said wasn't my favorite
youtubers live stream from a bathtub
that would be an interesting thing to
send to your your instructors as for why
you didn't get work done we'll see if
that works
you remind me of Jack Harkness
um I have my Harkness days I won't lie
dear God I have conservative parents and
if they walk in it would be a lot to
explain I think if your conservative
parents saw you watching me even not in
this setting then probably be questions
that would need to be answered
I don't do particularly conservative
minded people I tend to throw them off
on sight you know even before I start
talking mm let's see we BRE ranking the
doctor I don't know that was the doctors
or the doctor sees I'm not planning on
doing any fresh well oh I'll back up I
might I'm gonna wait a little bit cuz I
kinda need some distance from series 12
I might do a rear ANCA of the series
Aziz's I'm not gonna rewrite the doctors
until Whitaker's wrapped up her run
similarly I'm not gonna rewrite the
masters until we've had at least one
more series of Sasha diwan's master I am
possibly not until he has finished his
run as well so those things are on hold
I may do a series rearrange um not this
month maybe next month uh no I don't
know I don't have the docket directly in
front of me mm see the funny thing is
did you see the Rose prequel I saw that
it went up um I did I didn't get into it
is this a proper bathroom Lane like with
the room no this is this is a this is a
proper full bath is that there's the tub
it has a shower sink actually the the
washer/dryer up here too so ya know it's
it's a powerful thing
it's got a closet the bathroom has its
own closet actually live in a fairly big
house I I don't I don't place like do a
full tour of my house that's a little
privacy invasive but it's strictly
speaking is bigger than I
Ede but I like it so there you go
I really vibe with Sasha as the master I
did enjoy him I would like to see a bit
more of him not being the catalyst for a
mystery box so I want to see what he's
like when his story is not so directly
tied to whatever the series arc is and
that may sound like well why would you
bring back the master if you're not
gonna involve me in the series art
except that I would say all of Missy's
best stuff was fairly superfluous to
series art material so I kind of want to
see what he does when he's not when he
doesn't have to play a series narrative
device as much as a character stream
through all the isolation well here's
the funny thing
now are you gonna rank the sonic
screwdrivers I get that question every
now and then and I've put it up multiple
times in the patreon for when I've asked
the patreon supporters to pick which
list they want me to do and it's number
one so like I know people want it and I
keep offering it up but it it doesn't
get voted on so there's a plug for
patreon I suppose you want to lend your
voice to those poles when they come up
you can vote at any tier support here's
the funny thing right now I'm actually
sweating a little bit because I do baths
right on the border of scalding so even
though my arm and my head have not gone
in the water I am I am actually starting
to sweat
from the heat and from the steam coming
out of the bat so by my not properly
submerging it's it's sort of a
combination bath and sauna which now
that I can feel the beads of sweat right
right there at the temple
bubble elbow mm-hmm now I'm running up
run out of bottles hold on I've got a
little mm-hmm yes bubble oh wow uh-huh
bhana I don't know that that sounds like
a euphemism for something unpleasant are
you going to review PS yes
yes I am so many people have been asking
from for a while whether I was gonna be
yes I'm going to review PS what I need
to do is I need to decide whether or not
I'm going to lump it together with the
great detective
which I know um like they don't go
together
but I don't know if I'm gonna get a full
videos worth of material out of just
talking about PS so I need to figure how
many things I have to say about it
before I decide whether I'm gonna do it
by itself or lump it with another one of
the supporting shorts
I feel like ranking the sonic
screwdrivers and I've lost it sorry yeah
if you write something wrong it's gonna
get bumped out you getting Disney Plus I
haven't done it yet um that said I have
seen the mandalorian because I have a
friend who has it I can't thank you for
getting that I finished that series um
would you recommend red dwarf and Buffy
yes yes to both I have to go to bed will
not have to what I'm tired that is fair
first life seeing them once this is the
way hmm I have spoken and I'm see it's
funny because I've seen the Mandalorian
um criticized by some folks as being
very safe I suppose in a way it kind of
is especially form I go to sweat on my
lenses especially for any fans who like
kept up with the expanding universe
before that was turned into Star Wars
legends in May
Kanon because it's that kind of thing
that they did a lot so in many ways it
is like an expanding universe story just
on as a TV show and if you've already
been following that kind of material
then you know you're going to feel like
this is very familiar whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing that'll vary
from person to person but I think this
here's the thing about the mandalorian I
think it is a valid way to do Star Wars
I don't want it to become the only way
that Star Wars is done in terms of this
bit more nostalgia driven because look
for all my problems with the last Jedi I
don't fault it for trying to go into a
new direction
it did not work for me but I don't feel
that that's an inherently bad thing or
something that the franchise should stop
doing so while the Mandalorian is a bit
of a a warm gentle nostalgia bath um and
there are certainly there's certainly an
is-4 that I don't want that to become
all that new Star Wars material is so
that's where I'm nervous there's a risk
a life yeah but is there a
feature-length episode of Red Dwarf um
back to earth maybe I can't remember how
long that is
I always thought the ones back to earth
is is a weird beast and I remember
filing that under good execution of a
bad idea like the core concepts of back
to earth I didn't like at all but if
they were gonna do that idea they did it
pretty well at door of seasons 7 & 8
opinions oh I need to remember which is
which like my favorites are are one
through three just because that's what
first hooked me into it hang on I'm not
sick I had a little wine that was like
dangling on the edge of going down the
wrong pipe so like those are my
nostalgia
favorites but there's certainly good
stuff in the later series um it was it
was they were they'd found Red Dwarf
again as I recall I remember thinking
again that I that core idea that see
that series I didn't like but the
episodes weren't bad um I did think it
was a bit of a step down though um what
would be your ideal Doctor Who episode
Oh see if we're talking modern whoo I
honestly don't know but the thing is
there were different the Doctor Who
episodes that I love I love for
different reasons cuz they do different
things you know I love midnight for
different reasons than Vincent and the
doctor for different reasons than Heaven
Sent for different reasons than mummy on
the Orient Express for different reasons
then can you hear me so there is no one
ideal story for me of Doctor Who not in
the modern era at least I do think it's
distinctly possible that city of death
the Fourth Doctor serial might be the
closest to being my ideal of Doctor Who
but I hesitate to say that they should
go back to that because when you
compress that down to about half the
length it doesn't quite have enough room
to breathe so what I love about city of
death is it has an intriguing
you know time-bending concept behind it
it has terrific chemistry and lines and
riffs between the characters and it's
very funny but the thing is you condense
that down to a single episode you
condense that down to 45 minutes and you
have to sacrifice one of those basically
you have to decide is this a funny
episode is this a mind-bending episode
is this a we're trying to make the
parallel seem really tan
episode back in the classic era you had
the time to have an episode do multiple
things and there are some cheap partners
that come close I'd say something like
the empty child doctor dances is about
as close as I'd seen new who gets a sort
of my Platonic ideal of what Doctor Who
is but again keep in mind but a huge
part of what I love about Doctor Who is
the freedom that it's kind of loud
because you can travel anywhere in time
and space
that frees you up to have completely
different tones from episode to episode
so even as I say that I still wouldn't
want a Doctor Who series where every
episode had that feeling that vibe the
variety is a big part of it to me even
when the variety doesn't work like
series 11 cuz that variety did not work
for me but I still appreciate that it
was it was a buffet table with many
different flavors I wish I'd liked more
of them but you know all these things
are going by so fast we'd be writing the
sweaters nice
I really am sweating at this point oh
dear Torchwood opinion I've only seen
series one two and children of Earth I
haven't seen Miracle Day I haven't taken
in any of the Big Finish I never read
the stuff Torchwood was something that I
was fine aren't with on paper the only
time I thought it actually worked
at least that I saw was children of
Earth and the rest of the time like
there were sporadic episodes that were
good but like as a
as a thing over like this is why I have
no intention of doing an episode by
episode review of Torchwood because I
don't really one to rewatch Torchwood
and even children of Earth somebody had
to Commission me to get me to do that
I'm glad they did I was I was happy to
rewatch it but it Torchwood was an
interesting failure is my opinion of it
other people like to a lot and that's
great my standard answer is I'm glad you
liked it I wish I did and that's true in
virtually all cases there are very few
shows or episodes or movies where you
liking it is going to cause me to judge
you in some way I'm not going to say
there are none but there's very few by
and large my my if you like something I
don't I'm just gonna go I'm glad you
liked it at least somebody should oh
that's lovely
um somebody put up a rumours things and
it it just zoom by I love your hands
that okay see it's funny because with my
hands hanging out downward like this
like you can really see my veins and
this isn't like having to do with my age
like I've always had incredibly
prominent veins and when I've got
gravity working with me and you know all
the blood is kind of pooling in them
they're like they are they're crazy
visible like mm-hmm
look at this I mean if that's your thing
that's fine to any doctor who's audio
stories on your wishlist on my wishlist
no because I buy them directly from Big
Finish
by and large I do have have some that I
have actually listened to and done
reviews on and those will be going up in
the future and I'll leave it at that for
now
anywho tubers you want to do a collab
with oh my god
I mean all right setting aside the fact
that I've already done collaborations
with Ace creeper crispy Pro and stew bag
full all of whom I would happily work
with again but setting that aside and
going with ones who I have not done
anything with ah let me think so I mean
you can decide for yourself whether you
want to count the amount the inclusions
I had for for things like the who to
rewards as collaborations I I have been
meaning to do something with Wayne E
wingy media forever and it just
seriously guys the logistics of planning
this stuff when you have a full-time job
and a kid is nuts
so yeah so that that hasn't happened yet
but I have I have talked to him mr.
TARDIS reviews I'd be up for might
depend on the topic I know theories has
reached out to me I could get back to
him and I because off the top my head I
can't I can't remember what is topic
suggestion was so I can't remember if it
was time to series 12 or not and I
couldn't make it work at that time so I
should get back in touch with him again
I hope you'd consider him a who tuber
cuz it kind of jumps topics a lot but
I'd be happy to do something with
channel pub I enjoy his work drink
recommendations whatever you like like
what I like to drink may not be what you
like to drink at the moment I'm drinking
a mixture of cranberry juice and Malbec
red wine and I've got a fridge stocked
with hard cider and I have what else oh
my god Oh Oh got a Riesling I'm saving
that one that one that one is an
emergency bottle coz recent like my
normal go to wine why did you ruin
cranberry juice okay I'm gonna point out
it wasn't remember due to cocktail it
was like the real stuff like the
straight-up legit
cranberry juice which I am capable of
drinking but it's a little harsh all
right I like to think that adding red
wine is more on Ilan's how do a reminder
pop up it's more mellowing out the
cranberry juice then adding cranberry
juice to the wine if you could have a
Doctor Who spin-off what would be um see
that's tough because the first things
off the top my head have already been
done by Big Finish like Missy has her
own series on Big Finish and I would
totally have watched a spin-off about
missing like spin-offs spin-offs aren't
usually my bag
broadly speaking true later there's any
others that like what actually be
something I would I would give a shot to
and watch because I never got around to
class because that felt so tangental
tangential I don't know I'm drifting um
but yeah I don't know spin-offs so
rarely work I don't tend to think in
terms of spin-offs most of the time
especially considering I don't feel like
dr. who needs spin-offs because it gets
such a complete refresh with each new
doctor and each new showrunner so the
general nature of a spinoff to have
something in that world that feels
different you can already get in the
show itself just by Rhys just by
resetting with a new doctor so maybe
that's part of why I don't think too
much less somebody mentioned the time
work like I I have no interest in the
time war I have at this point listen to
excuse me two different Big Finish box
sets that had the time or has an impact
and one of them I liked pretty well some
interesting stuff the other one I did
not like very much at all and the whole
thing with the time wars like to me the
time war shouldn't it should be a
conflict that is waged in a way that is
unfathomable to us to even try to tell
stories within that I think is a fool's
errand because it inherently demystifies
it now
if you wanted to tell stories about
someone impacted by the time war
somebody you know a civilization a group
of people or whatever on the outskirts
of it and what it does to them I can
work with that because most of the time
war stories I've heard and I say her
because they've all been big finish have
basically done that word the presence of
the time war was either a looming threat
or its fallout had some sort of impact
on the story but the story itself was
not set in the heart of the thing
because those stories I really don't
care are you gonna review classic series
once you finish over do who I've been
doing classic reviews on the podcast on
the council of geeks podcast which I
don't plug anymore because I updated so
infrequently but that's where I've been
putting classic food reviews and the
reason for that is the stupidest
possible reason which is that the views
on classic reviews were always
significantly lower they actually sort
of they tended to fall below my normal
threshold for what I consider to be a
successful video so committing to doing
videos on classic who basically meant
committing myself to release
underperforming material on a regular
basis and that's just in the reality of
YouTube that's a bad
yeah so that's the reason I started
reviewing on the podcast was to
basically give me a reason to keep I
mean not that I don't like it anyway but
my time is so limited I kind of need to
be reviewing in some way otherwise I
don't get to stuff so that's been why I
started doing those on the podcast now
huh that was supposed to be weekly then
bi-weekly at this point it's been
monthly and I would like to pick up the
speed on that I can't promise that well
but go ahead and subscribe to the
council of geeks podcast to keep up with
those somebody asked what I think of a
third doctor I think Jon Pertwee is
great I think he's incredibly charming
his era I have slightly more expands
about but he's terrific
like here's the thing they're really
only two doctors that I don't
particularly care for and then the rest
of them no matter where they would fall
in a ranking that I might do or have
done I still like them it's just a
question of liking others more so the
only ones that I don't really care for
are the war doctor and the fifth doctor
and in both cases I wish I liked them I
wish I got more out of them but I just
they don't click with me to be fair with
the war doctor there's less material for
me to try and keep finding a way to
connect to it but you know that's just
the reality of it with the third doctor
I mostly remember the sexism okay but
did you remember that legitimately or
did that crop up when that video of jon
pertwee being the doctor in the 80s for
some sort of office thing talking about
computers when that made its rounds
around Twitter because I feel like that
put a like and made people go oh I'm not
saying it's not there but for me for the
most part it has rarely derailed my
enjoyment of a story in Doctor Who so
you know your mileage may vary what do
you think of Adric
Adric was a mistake controversial
question who should follow on from Jodi
I would just say let Joe Martin take it
up after this
like honestly I warned you but nominals
you get you I'm watching these things
scroll past you do a longer comment I'm
not gonna catch it who's your favorite
Farscape character or - oh I'm this this
is I'm not sure it's a deep cut but only
people who really know the show will
know this woman I think Harvey it's
probably my favorite Farscape character
I really really love him
beyond that I know I do really like
Crichton I feel like he's one of the
better leads and a sci-fi show like that
because usually the the leads have a
tendency to be either boring or to suck
all the oxygen of the room so nobody
else gets a shot and he does neither of
those things but still really works
I loved Harvey - ah nice
oh nice type of approval on that what do
you think of Nyssa and have you heard of
Justin Ayers I am familiar with jaws
snares and I am also familiar with his
companion ranking scheme as to how Nyssa
each companion is witness of being the
highest possible rank I enjoy Nyssa I
don't think at least over the course of
the stories that I've seen of the fifth
doctor I don't think that Nyssa was
particularly well utilized but I
actually argue that about most of the
Companions did you ever watch the show
Lex I didn't I mean I knew it was a
thing hold on somebody did a super Chad
do you think a
should have been in the time war no not
really because my I first of all I love
that of the doctor not only for his
performance but because I think that
whole concept is very cool that there's
a there's a doctor basically whose
entire existence began and ended with
being in the time war I think that's a
neat idea even though I don't
particularly like the war doctor so love
some legs yeah I feel like I watched an
episode or two of Lex and it didn't
quite gel with me I'm not sure why not
I remember being on the Sci Fi Channel
like at the same time and well not like
literally the same time but around the
same time as Farscape how much does your
thoughts on the six not improved since
you've excuse me I'm heard as being
finished up good immeasurably The Sixth
Doctor is done so much better in be
finished then he was ever done on the
show proper it's it is insane how much
better he is and I do put a lot of that
down to pairing him with much better
companions especially evylyn Smyth she
was the perfect companion to him and he
didn't really work with the other ones
that he was given so have you ever watch
the Sarah Jane Adventures and in family
would you watch it back I feel like I
answered that question on Wow um I've
seen the first two series of the Sarah
Jane Adventures they were fine I I don't
love it but it's not because it's bad
it's because it's aimed at such a much
younger demographic then I am a part of
that it just it just doesn't connect
with me it's the kind of show that is
pitched at such a young age that I mean
that at least for me unless I grew up
with it I have a hard time watching it
so like to make a comparison there are
cartoons from the 80s that I love them
will happily rewatch like the Real
Ghostbusters like Thundercats but if I
try and watch the other shows that were
going on obscene
and we're probably of comparable quality
lights a GI Joe I can't get through them
because I have no nostalgia for them and
I feel like you kind of need the
nostalgia to get over the hump of things
aimed at a significantly younger
audience a lot of the time not always
but often and that's sort of the case
with me and Sarah Jane I'm gonna have to
wrap this up soon the water is starting
to cool off so see would you watch
Torchwood if they did new episodes or
are you almost fully done with it if
they did new episodes I can certainly
move stop walking loose there we go if
they did new episodes of Torchwood
I would certainly check them out um I
wouldn't be like against watching it but
I'm not asking for that to happen
what kind of master story would you
write um I'm not really thought about it
because I feel like you would write a
very different story for any given
master or not any given master bow
um so I have to settle on what master I
will be writing before I can even think
about something about that but like my
brain doesn't really work that way
because I know that I will never have
the opportunity to do that so that's why
that's part of why I'm really bad at
things like fan theory or how I would
run a show or what have you because if I
try and do those exercises part of my
brain goes why are you spending creative
energy on this it will never happen and
it makes it really hard for me to
progress down that thought process that
you need to to do things like fan
theories and speculation videos even to
be honest you heard of the 90-minute red
door special coming next month I have um
that's about all I know I just know it's
a thing
have you ever seen the Doctor Who
EastEnders crossover hit yes the odds if
not would you I have not seen it I'm
aware of it it's on the list of things
to maybe eventually do at some point so
unless somebody Commission's me to do it
probably not anytime soon so this water
has drawn lukewarm on me so I am going
to call it call it a night so hope you
have fun I'm sorry we couldn't do what
was originally planned the box swooped
in so fast so thanks for stopping in um
I hope that you are all staying safe
whatever you need to do to unwind and
relax obviously you see what I have
opted to do today so stay safe be well
and remember you are beautiful you are
valid you are loved you're the counsel
I'm just fine the meetings tonight from
okay have a good night folks